and i'm now joined by adam thielen wide
receiver for the vikings joining us
during his bye week before he gets set
to take on the cowboys for sunday night
football so adam thanks so much for
joining us on sunday football final how
did you spend your time off this week
yeah a lot of family time wrangling kids
up and uh
cooking out just got done cooking out a
little bit of food watching the game so
uh definitely i tell my wife it's almost
like a uh
vacation for me when i actually go into
the facility
just because i get a little bit of quiet
time but it was uh it's just been good
well let's stay on that subject because
you and your wife caitlin welcome to
baby girl cora just this past june she
joins her two big brothers so how is it
being a family of five right now
it's busy it's it's a lot of work
especially during the season i'm
thankful that my wife is
um you know she's an unbelievable woman
and just kind of uh carries a lot of
tasks and loads on her and and uh we're
thankful that she's so strong and just
willing to do so much to his family but
yeah it's been it's been great you know
having a little girl in the house has
been a great change up for us having two
crazy boys but uh she's a sweetheart and
um definitely is a great addition to
this family yeah you say the three crazy
boys but i love seeing the videos you
post on instagram where they're so
gentle with her and you can tell they're
going to be just amazing big brothers to
baby cora well you won't be
trick-or-treating next sunday because
you've got a big match-up on sunday
night football against the cowboys they
are in town the first few games adam for
you guys didn't quite get the results
that you wanted and then you've had some
close ones five of the six games have
gone down to the final play so what have
you learned about your team so far this
season
just resiliency you know just a bunch of
guys that um not focus on results
obviously we want wins uh but just focus
on the process and loving each other
having fun with our you know one another
you know the mindset hasn't changed from
week to week through a couple of bad
losses in a row
you know a couple close wins uh
everybody's kind of mindset's the same
so it's it's been really fun to be in
that locker room and just see uh the
attitudes of guys day in and day out and
um you know it's those things that you
look to late in the season and say hey
we've been here before uh we've been
through tough times been through good
times and um just you know you hope you
can get on a roll and remember you know
what it took to get to where you are now
and for you personally adam five
touchdowns on the season how is that
connection building between you and your
quarterback kirk cousins so far
well i always say you know it takes so
many reps to get on the same page of a
quarterback and and whether that be in
the summer otas training camp you know
obviously regular season games um
there's so many reps it takes to really
understand what each other um you know
you know the way that you're thinking
the way that you're doing different
things um and i feel like you know it's
one of those things where
now we've had so many reps on her belt
that that he kind of knows what i'm
gonna do um in certain situations and i
know what he's gonna do so i'm thankful
for that and and uh he's he does the
little things to make sure that
everybody feels that way you know he's
having the young guys stay after
practice and and get some routes that he
knows are going to show up in the game
and i think it's those little things um
it's not attention to detail that really
makes him great
let's talk about the cowboys for a
second because this is a much improved
dallas defense with some really exciting
players like trayvon diggs who's
lighting up the league right now what is
the approach when you are facing a game
changer type player like trayvon diggs
yeah i mean you got to be attentive to
detail you have to really be focused on
the process um and and you can't just
show up on sunday and think that uh it's
gonna be easy um you gotta know uh what
you're gonna get yourself into uh that
week um you gotta prepare and then on
game day you gotta bring your best up uh
he's he's a great player he's a
game-changing uh corner by the way that
he makes plays at the bottom here uh i
i've known him for a long time because
of his older brother so um we'll be
interested in competing against him but
uh we'll be good to see him i'm curious
you mentioned earlier in the interview
that you're just kind of cooking at home
and you're watching some of the games on
sunday on this bye week you know when
you're watching nfl games what are you
are you relaxed or what's your thought
process and the particular games you're
keeping an eye on for
yeah i'm super relaxed i get to just
watch as a fan um you know
people always ask you know do you do you
use it as you know study film uh do you
you know do you actually scout teams
you're gonna be playing the next few
weeks and i used to as a young player i
used to be like all right the packers
are playing tonight um i'm gonna watch
them because we play them next week and
uh you know try to you know get against
an advanced scout on them but on tv you
just can't see it well enough to even
temper to even matter so uh for me i
just watch as a fan and then when i when
i want to do my study i can go on the
ipad and i can get a better look there
but uh it's fun to just kind of take
yourself out of it and just watch from a
different perspective that's awesome i
love it well i have to talk about your
foundation because you guys are doing
amazing work at the phelan foundation
recently hosting an event uh with top
golf this foundation focuses on using
the power of sport to change society so
adam can you share a little bit more
about your foundation and why it's so
important to you
yeah my wife and i um we have a special
place in our heart for youth um and
specifically youth um you know kids and
um that really don't have the resources
opportunities uh that we had growing up
that really helped us be able to play
high school sports to be able to go on
to college so
really just
helping provide those opportunities
resources
to these kids and to really just kind of
bring those communities around them the
last thing that we were able to do
recently was provide lights for a high
school football team and uh well really
a high school you know they can play
soccer under their football and to be
able to see the community be able to
come out there and support them for the
first time in a long time uh they've
been without lights and and they've had
to play games at three o'clock and their
families weren't able to come the
community wasn't able to come and just
to be able to see
that community support and how that
changes those kids mentality
is really really special and obviously
a great community here that is
supportive of these different tasks um
the people that do have the resources
they're really all on board of helping
us and really changing these communities
um that means so much to my wife and i
well adam is truly admirable to see what
you and caitlin are doing there off the
field it's been fun to watch you on the
field this season as well and we'll look
forward to seeing you again on sunday
night football against the cowboys the
good luck next week thanks so much for
taking the time to join us
yeah thank you so much appreciate it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports